and so how often in your own lives are
you sort of having those same kind of
thoughts the kind of thoughts you're
putting into your store in terms of life
okay I wish I can just go back two years
or these kind of like as you say low
side by low fights on five thoughts or
how often is that is that like a daily
thing we know especially between you two
are the kind of conversations you often
find ourselves that's funny I was
actually thinking about that the other
day as I was like crafting a Twitter
message i was thinking like I wish I had
a TARDIS from it's like from Doctor to
the space machine um it's like I wish I
had a TARDIS to go back and like stark
you know like try it over or do a couple
things different and then I didn't tell
you this video I started geeked out over
my own thought of it was like well but I
can't because I can't change my own
timeline like that would be wrong and it
started very caring this but of like I
like asking myself this question of
would I change amount i'm like timeline
and ship it changed i won then I felt
really embarrassed when I was making
these things but I think it's human
nature to sort of I mean that like to
have these thoughts of like like these
interesting I guess inventions up these
sci-fi type of things that don't exist
like time machines and no portals and I
don't know fine no space things but if
it gets its human nature today to really
think of the what if and I think that's
what's so fun about sci-fi because it's
all about the what if the what if and
then what but it may be because we're
also both really big geeks that we think
of I don't know how much the average
person thinks about that yeah I'm kind
of obsessed with Tom in time concepts
and and things like that and that's why
you know the other aspect of fact that
Vikram he has these photos like that's
why he's from the future and he finds
out that he's going to be responsible
for all of these events but he hasn't
done them yet um yet he has the entire
path of his story laid out in front of
him and so um you know
if there are noble things is he noble if
they're bad things you know he just lets
them happen um you know what kind of
person does that make him and you know
the fact that he can't stop it no matter
what he does at what point does he give
up trying to stop it and then if
something does change just a little bit
like let's say for example like all
these pictures never change but finally
someone's looking left instead of
looking right in one of the photos like
what does that mean for everything else
after that and those kinds of ideas i
just find really really interesting I'm
fun to play with this the idea like you
predetermination or late destiny you
know I think any sometimes after
something happens like this is real life
obviously you you look back at something
and you make connections on your own you
know you're like oh that happened
because of that or I'm lucky that that
happened because that led to this in
your backward year making those
connections backwards but then it's kind
of fun to think about it it's like well
maybe that's how it was always supposed
to happen and we throw we have those
throwaway comments all the time it's
like I was meant to be here this might
happen and you never really stop and
think of me cool was it like is there
something that's Drive you met lake yeah
and if you can change it how much can
you change it yeah I mean that and does
that begin to sort of freak you out when
you really start to think about it or is
there something where you sort of them
embrace it a little bit okay um I think
I kind of embrace it on a personal level
at just yeah I can relate to it
you